I still can't believe I agreed to do
this.
Well, 20 years ago, you couldn't prompt
your way into a poem, but uh it's a
little bit easier now. Um, and the
prompt I put in for this is that I'm a
50 plus person who grew up programming a
little, but not really a programmer by
trade. and I was going to security
conference and uh over the last nine
months I think I've written 35 apps with
very little programming knowledge and
what are the risks uh that have to do
with that but I'll I'll share the prompt
maybe in the slack a little bit later
all right here we go when every employee
codes by feel and prompts replace the
change control seal the orchard bends
the backlog breaks as product ships and
coffee breaks marketing scripts trips a
pricing bot finance deploys what forgot
HR wires flows at half three relax they
say it's YAML see five coding hums
through every floor ideas sprint
straight out the door a thousand apps by
end of week all clever fast and mildly
bleak for castles fell when walls were
tall now there are simply no walls at
all the perimeter packed up and took
leave replaced by tokens we barely
perceive agents is calling agents deep
with scopes too broad and guards asleep.
A plug-in pulls from who knows where and
slips malicious code in there. A breach
no longer kicks the door. It forks a
repo and it certainly asks for more.
Vulnerability softly bloom in CI
pipelines glowing room. A library six
months out of date. An unchecked input
at the gate. A prompt injection dressed
as help that makes your agent hand out
wealth.
Lease privilege stretched paper thin
service accounts with god mode in test
credentials left behind in logs no one
was paid to mind in zero day it shifts
its frame no longer just an unknown name
zero day is now the space between a
prompt and prod embrace when code
appears at human speed before a
scanner's had time to read zero day is
vibe at scale where governance arrives
by credit check mail zero day is trust
misplaced it's autogenerated ated haste
a model certain clean concise and
catastrophically imprecise.
So scan the prompt and sign the claim
vera of control thy way thy why not name
log the agent bind its reach assume that
automation can breach for breaches
thrive in silent drift in tiny scopes
that slowly shift and safely lives in
teams who choose to ship with scare and
logs to prove build boldly. Let the
builders play. Let innovation light the
way. But in this world of instant code,
secure the path where vibes explode.